I do understand we have a very special
guest with Maurice in studio
that's right Dennis Hummel is with
Maurice yes we have a lot of people who
give to the club a lot of organizations
that believe in the mission of the club
and one of them is merit holdings and
Dennis Hummel who is a vice chairman
Dennis thank you so much for joining us
you are quite welcome I'm delighted to
be here tell us a little bit about
merits because when I was researching
your company it was a watch company back
in the day and a long long time ago but
now it's involved in so much
customer experience improving growth
sales incentive z' tell us what exact
exactly that means
so merits is in the people business and
you know we have a company that's
founded on helping our customers address
the issues of people and behavior with
their employees with their customers and
with their partners their channel
partners in all realms whether it to be
loyalty customer satisfaction employee
engagement incentive programs you know
as you pointed out it started as a do
this do this get that kind of company
right and now it's morphed into a lot
more of the psychology of the human mind
and how to leverage it we could use some
of that here well why is it then that
marriage to decided that they would like
to help responds to chess you've been
sponsoring chess now for two years we
have the merits family and merits is
focused on education
I'm a former educator I started my
career as a high school educator so it's
a big topic for us and it's somewhat
self-serving because we need good talent
and with the desire that we have to
continue to feed our needs with talented
professionals we know that that starts
really early in in each of us and chess
is a wonderful way in my opinion to
teach some of the most critical elements
of critical thinking and
the intellect necessary to feed our
business model very well said I
understand that you went to Bowling
Green State University I did go Falcons
go Falcon did I overhear that you were
you were on the radio as well I did do a
radio show back in the day a long long
time ago in a place far far away and as
I've said I have a face for radio so I
did some television for deaf television
production work and some behind the
scenes camera work hi how you enjoying
what's happening I am enjoying it I like
this this is kind of cool I do I do I do
I actually taught my son how to play
he quickly taught me that he was a lot
better than I was at the critical
thinking side of chess and he actually
played in high school he played chess
here at a local high school fantastic
what can we expect from Maris in the
near future and the continuing
engagement of the club well we're very
excited about being a part of the Chess
Club here we recognize that it teaches a
lot of those very critical as elements
of what it takes to be a good
contributor not only society but to the
business world the critical thinking
aspects the the strategic thinking the
reaction and the ability to be reactive
to unforeseen changes in the opponent
and and to be competitive so we will
continue to make investments in the in
the st. Louis chess club as a part of
our corporate giving initiative you know
every time someone like you comes on and
you speak so highly of whether the clubs
doing always say so does this mean
you're gonna give double the money the
next time well the good news is I don't
actually get to make that decision we
have a a corporate giving Council that
are made up of employees in the company
and I give the chairman a lot of credit
rather than make those decisions himself
he has given them a pool of funds from
which they can then assess and today we
were involved in over 300 different
engagements we put last year 3,000 of
our own hours employee hours to
volunteering and we participate on 17
boards of the various corporate or the
various fundations that we are involved
in that's absolutely fantastic well
thought through
fantastic work you guys are doing Dennis
Hummel vice chairman of merits holdings
keep doing great work I would say the
same to the st. Louis chess club and the
u.s. chess foundation I mean this is
this is this is critical important
fundamental development of our young
people and it is so important not only
to merits to this community but to our
country so well done on your end as well
thank you very much for recognizing that
and good luck with everything
thank you sir it's a pleasure thank you
for joining us and from everything
you've said it really sounds to me like
you're in the investing in people
business and I just love what you guys
are doing are you unique in your
approach because we need more people
like you this is great thank you
we are really truly blessed I've said
many times when I was in the PC business
before I came to merits and the one
thing that you know in any given time
any 50% of our customers are unhappy for
one reason or another one I came here
every time you talk to someone that's
touched by one of our programs they
almost always smile because we remind
them of them something they've done well
we ask them their opinion and we get
them together with others that they
might know that ever made so it's a kind
of a cool place to work with the chess
club here mark the joy pray about this
folks
I'm kidding they treat us quite well
here as well there hey thank you so much
the pleasure thank you thank thank you